So today's session is on the globalization,
secularization and transformation of faiths
and
we don't have Tony Blair with us,
we don't have of an additional resource
person with us, so you're kind of stuck with
me and with Doug
for this course. What I'll try
to do is maybe offer just a bit more
extended introductory comments on the topic
and then
open it up for for discussion, and this may
be an opportunity also
to kind of range a bit more broadly in terms of
of your questions about faith
than just the topic of this
session that's to look back
as well as maybe anticipate the future.
And then I thought what I might do
in the second
part of our
session
is to take the question that has surfaced
very prominently and very quickly in the session
which we had with Tony Blair,
and that is the question of religious exclusivism
and the relationship between religious exclusivism
and
a kind of promotion of
pluralism as a
social value or as a political project.
The relationship between exclusive religious
claims
and a pluralistic environments in which we
find ourselves and in which globalization processes
are increasingly created.
So I have developed some comments on
this. It was an essential
element, almost a red thread of the
the discussions last year.
I think it was the first session that it was raised
just like you did,
which we should have built in
reading about it and time
for reflection on this. We didn't but as
it turns out we'll have probably
thirty five, forty minutes on that.
That's as long as you want to deal
with the issue.
So, first
we talked a bit about significance
of faith. We don't need to repeat any
of this and we are obviously dealing with the question of secularization
and transformation of faiths.
We're obviously dealing with the future
of faiths in the globalized world
and
that future concerns
questions of religious adherence
will faiths, do faiths continue to claim the hearts
and minds of people around the globe
as much as they did
in the past? For instance that's a
question we need to answer and
the answer is yes, in particular Islam and
Christianity, Buddhism,
these three faiths are growing in numerical terms, in relative and absolute terms as
I said
previously.
Will they do so in the future? Well,
they'll most likely
if you extrapolate from the basis of data that we have now,
it's likely it's going to continue
to be that way.
What will those numbers be? Well, it's tough
to tough to say,
but it does look
like in the immediate future at least the
world's going to get to be
a bit more--
for some I should say an even more--
religious place than it is right now.
Now the connected question to
this is not just that of religious
adherence;
we're also interested in the role of faith in
public realm. Are faiths
a force that shapes realities
beyond people's private
and narrowly communal lives?
And we've seen previously arguments which would
suggest
no, faiths are something very much private.
Faiths are if you want belief in the phenomenal.
They don't shape anything, they are shaped by
something, conditioned by other things,
but they themselves are
some people would even argue sternly causally inert.
They don't do anything, right? They just
come to surface given certain conditions.
I'm pretty sure
that's not quite right but at least that's
one of the possibilities.
And they are shaping
realities beyond private and narrow communal
lives of people.
Will they continue to do so in the future,
and in what ways faiths will be significant?
And then there's a question also of the character
of faiths.
How is the
character, the forms that faiths take
being shaped
by globalization
processes,
and
given
that faiths are being shaped by globalization processes if they indeed are,
how do the influences go
in complex ways?
So,
that's roughly what we're going to be talking
about, but first a few comments on secularization.
So, I want to give you
a few,
mention a few aspects of secularization.
Often when we talk but secularization
we end up talking past
each other because
the word secularization is used
in at least three distinct ways, and
it's important to know what we're
dealing, how we're using the word
when we're using it. So,
first sense of secularization is
differentiation
of secular spheres,
which is to say the differentiation of society
and in that society
emancipation of, say, state
of economy
of media, broad
spheres of life,
from immediate or from even media influence
of religious institutions
and possibly even religious norms.
Now, adverse of
this
is what sociologists call
privatization of religion,
that is if religion is not shaping how state
is being run, how economy is being run, well,
then religion is
increasingly has become a private affair
of individuals.
So that secularization in one sense
is differentiation.
Second sense in which secularization is used
is simply decline
of religious belief in practice.
People simply turning away from belief in God,
and people turning away from religious practices that
there may be discrepancies there, right?
Many people can say that they believe in God,
but they don't
attend worship services,
or they worship services that don't
very much matter in their lives.
There's ways in which
this decline of religious belief
and practice can be
expressed.
And then final
sense
is change in
conditions of belief,
and this has been introduced
in a book,
most compelling in a book
by Charles Taylor,
"A Secular Age".
It's a kind of doorstopper
book. It can inflict serious damage
if you wield it
inappropriate or in in inappropriate ways.
And it's a long, windy story which
Charles Taylor tells,
but he is one of the the great philosophers
of out time,
and this is really one of
great books on secularization
issue, but his question is
how did we come
to move away from a society where belief in God
was unchallenged and unproblematic,
something like fifteen
hundreds, right,
to a society or to a cultural environment in
which faith is understood to be one option
among others
and often an option which is not
the easiest one to embrace.
So he is asking
conditions of belief have shifted in such a way
that
you have to choose
that faith among multiplicity of options rather
than kind of
slipping into it
as a state of normalcy in which society
operates.
Now we will be
interested primarily in the first two aspects of secularization,
in decline of individual
religious practice,
and belief can be seen as an aspect of practice,
and secondly in decline
of cultural influence of faiths.
I don't think we should bother too much
with a question about
the future
of religion,
and often secularization is
discussed in those
terms.
And some people then expect
eventual demise of
religion
almost like a
as a matter of
linear understanding of history. It's part
of the philosophy of history that religion
ought to
or that religion will
experience demise.
Or as kind of projectoral
extrapolation from dots, and we're not
so much interested in that, not just because
this is not easy to answer this question,
but because I think for the purposes of
this course it's not
necessary for us
to answer this question. We're
talking about next decades;
we're not talking about ultimate future
of religion.
So, let's now look at
the relationship between globalization and
secularization.
now one thing I think
is right to say
is that globalization
is
and entails modernization.
Globalization is fueled, maybe primarily driven
by, modern market system.
It's mediated and helped by
technological advancements,
especially advancements in communication, but
other also technological advances.
And
I think globalization is
assuming and it's also
reinforcing
what sociologists call individuation,
so to say that individual is
you've seen that I think that Berger mentions that individual is taken out of
sort of traditional,
given identities
and thrown on his or her
own resources to make choices
about life.
And globalization
also means
rather fast-paced fashioning and refashioning
of
alternative, almost global culture.
I think something has happened on the global level
that's moving very fast in terms of cultural
change.
So all of these
elements I think are elements of modernization,
but now the question is whether
modernization
entails
secularization.
In authority one is the same modernization,
to modernize is to secularize,
and modernization
entails secularization,
decline of religion in society,
decline of religion in the minds of individuals,
then obviously
globalization, too,
will
entail secularization.
If religion survives then,
they survive because they're holding something from the past.
You know because modernization hasn't progressed
far enough
yet, or
because of social
inertia
or resurgence of religion
can be kind of last gasp of religion
before its final
demise.
Law professor here for whom I have great admiration,
it was my friend,
Tony Kronman, in conversations with
him he basically
expressed this opinion; what you see
this religious resurgence
is the kind of last gasp of religion before hah,
it gives out its
ghost.
The other alternative is
modernization
is not necessarily secularization,
which means
that there might be
religious ways
to be modern.
Embracing secularism
is one way to modernize.
Embracing faith
and holding onto faith
maybe an alternative way to modernize.
We'll encounter this concept
of alternative modernities
in the next session, especially the work of
Jose Casanova, who will be our guest here,
and I would encourage you to read carefully
the text assigned
for the next week, his text assigned for the next
week. I think that's one of the best
sociological analysis of what's happening
in the world of religion
today.
Charles Taylor himself is a strong and
sturdy
mainly philosophical advocate
but also sociological advocate of
alternative modernities.
So, if there are such alternative modernities, religious ways to modernize,
then obviously
globalization need not lead to secularization,
but as I sometimes say globalization
can be played in
multiple different registers.
There are different religious registers in which
globalization can be played,
and there's also secular,
presumably also multiple secular registers
in which it can be played depending
on the particular culture
in which
through which
globalization processes refract themselves.
So,
but the question for us is
not simply whether
it's possible for religion to
live together
with advancing globalization processes, and my argument
would be that secularization thesis has proven
not to be correct
at least for now,
but also
what might be the impact of globalization
processes
on the shape
which religions take.
And so I want to talk about now about globalization's
impact on faith.
There are a few points that I want to make here,
one of them being
globalization and the conditions under which
people embrace faith,
globalization and the form which faiths take,
globalization and the modes of transmission
of faith
and globalization and the modes of religious
influence,
shaping the way that religion influences.
So overarching conditions
under which people embrace faith,
but often it boils down to something like
a malcontent with globalization processes
or with life in general, right? Religious
people,
actually that would be too...
I can give a whole lecture
about the positive experience of
life
in association with embrace of religion,
but we'll
keep that later for another
class,
another course.
So, uh
for instance people experience
themselves as left out
from globalization's benefits,
and they're seeking consolation in faith
or possibly seeking inspiration to change
the rules so as to attend
to the losses of the so-called losers.
A variation of that is the experience of injustice
as a consequence of globalization
and maybe finding in faith
assurance
of future justice
or seeking motivation in faith to
struggle for justice.
You know that did this idea of
finding assurance in faith of future justice
is a very interesting how it emerged immediately after
World War 2,
and among some very prominent Jewish
thinkers.
And the basic idea, the basic intuition
was
it's somehow unacceptable
that the torturer
would eternally triumph
over the victim.
Some kind of sense of
that immense defeat
that Holocaust was
and the immense wrong that it
was and somehow crying for justice, a
search for Justice,
It's a very interesting small book
The longing
for
a radically different one.
Is that a good translation?
Third,
reason for embrace faith, believeing the
globalization undermines local cultures
and seeking affirmation of local cultures
through faith.
We see that very easily in former Yugoslavia,
right? It's partly connected with globalization process.
How faith attached itself to
itself to particular
ethnic identities.
Or experiencing disorientation in globalization
kind of being caught in the midst of globalization
can feel like
being in the swirling storm,
and then seeking guidance and certainty in faith.
Or sensing the meaninglessness of the ends
prevalent within globalization process,
and seeking meaning in faith.
I'm not suggesting that all people do it but some
religious people
that's how they experience globalization and then they seek meaning.
Or believing that globalization driven by
market forces undermines human flourishing
by over-privileging say consumers and
simply reinforcing rather than shaping human desires.
Something of that sort.
And then seeking alternative modes of human
flourishing
in faiths.
The globalization is shaping the very form
which faith takes
It's interesting phenomenon is
democratization of faith,
its steady
growth in the processes of
internal democratization
of faith's subversion of authoritarian forms
of faith
and even the forms of faith that have a strong
authority structures
nonetheless
incorporate in its own
internal structure democratic
elements.
Non-authoritarian governments and active
participation,
especially interesting here is inclusion of
women
in leadership roles
and empowerment of women in
leadership roles.
But also what's happening is that faiths tend
to be moored from particular locales
and
they tend to become global faiths, or put it
differently
it's only
easily transportable global faiths that seems
to be
surviving best and best adopted to
the world's caught
in globalization processes.
Somewhat in tension with this
is the idea
of rediscovery of culturally specific
forms the Fed
and you can see how globalization processes
might require,
must reckon cultural identities and faiths made and
take forms that are culturally specific.
And then interesting phenomenon and we
touched
briefly on this
is smorgasbord religiosity,
especially find it in western
culture or in kind of higher echelons
of
global culture.
It's kind of individually created
faith tailored to individual
needs. You've got nuggets of wisdom from
here and there.
You combine those, and you are then Jewbu, is that right,
well, or whatever else combination you can attach.
That's not exhaustive description, right,
of that and there are other permutations
and combinations of faiths and they're
tailor made to a particular person,
and they change also over time.
How your needs change, so your
religious sensibilities, and what you find
useful
from different religious traditions, so that
changes
as well.
And they're containing generally
kind of no overarching interpretation of
reality. They tend to be more
kind of spiritualities which energize,
which calm and soothe
rather than kind of order
the world as traditional
spiritual traditional faiths that...
And they have often a relatively highly
attenuated sense of ultimacy.
It's not that you have some
sturdy divinity up there, right, but rather
you're finding the God in the self,
that somehow there is
in each individual again divinities
tailor-made to the self.
C, globalization is shaping modes of transmission
of faith.
Just go back a little bit
about
this smorgasbord religiosity.
It also turns faiths into
kind of a lifestyle choice
that cannot be contested by others. In other words it
takes the faith
out of the domain of truth claims,
claims about what is true and claims
about what is called traditional faiths.
They generally understand
themselves as containing claims
about the world that are considered to be
true
and moral claims also.
A smorgasbord religiosity is a more
kind of a
lifestyle
religiosity.
They are preferences in the ways in which we
seek to conduct our lives
with kind of
a bit of religious aura
to them.
That's one way to put it.
Globalization is shaping modes of transmission of faith,
technologies of delivery.
Faiths are as present on internet
as they were
when radio was invented, as they were when
TV was in its heyday. TV evangelists,
notorious as they were, were ubiquitous.
I remember the first time I came to this
country, and I came as a student of theology, you know,
a very religious person
I was.
I stayed with a family and flipped through
channels
and came across this guys whose name was Ernest Angley,
dressed in this flamboyant
dress with a toupee on his head,
walking in this haute, airy way and then coming to people and
taking ghosts,
evil spirits of the ears, and I look,
my goodness where have I landed.
Is this religiosity in America? Wow.
Everything's possible, but in person you realize
that,
you know, that America is the land
of extremes, right, and everything in between,
also.
So technologies of delivery, right? New technologies
of delivery,
which I think feeds also into democratization
of religions
with very little formal authority
or authority that is earned in act, and so
the authority that is transmitted
through mass media often is
precisely such kind of authority,
especially
through internet, right?
New missionary movements
from east to west
not just from west to east. We're used to kind of thinking
Christianity as a missionary
religion goes from west to east.
The missionary movements goes the other way around.
Buddhism, the spread of buddhism for instance is
a very good example of that.
Or, the mission goes
from non-western to non-western
country. There's more missionary activities of
Christians
between
non-western countries than between
west and the western countries.
And then, Peter Berger has emphasized that, and
also kind of the response to Peter Berger
in part by Hans Joas.
Transmission of faith in the context
of competitive religious pluralism.
There's religious pluralism,
there's competition,
and that's how,
those are the conditions for
transmission.
And then finally globalization is shaping modes
of religious influence,
which is to say how globalization is shaping
the way in which faiths engage
globalization processes themselves.
One option is more traditional one:
religious authority,
representing an institution,
acting globally.
For instance when
Pope Benedict the sixteenth
speaks, that's how he acts, the Dalai lama
speaks, that's
probably how he acts as the religious authority.
But the other option is increasingly
prominent
and significant:
Informal religious authority
in the network of believers.
And it's kind of shaping subcultural
movement of global dimensions.
Bin Laden, right,
is a good example.
Or take it to American scene, most influential
religious figure in America is arguably Rick Warren,
right?
But his authority is
clearly the authority of his books.
He has no formal authority at all
except maybe in his own Saddleback Church,
and yet
his authority stretches not just in this
country but around the globe.
That, too, is made possible I think by
modernization and globalization processes.
Also up here and
opening it up for comments, questions on
what we've been discussing now,or
I'll also be broader about
religion or about this course. Okay.